on this episode I talk about periscope
what's my favorite airport and how do I
get over being young you ask questions
and I answer them this is the askgaryvee
show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're listening and watching to the ask
gary vee show episode 8 oh I'm gonna
give a big shout out to my boy Wayne
Chrebet classic all-time New York jet
hustler
you know 11th man on the depth chart
went all the way up to getting his
number retired last year
Wayne big shout-out he wore number 80
this is episode number 80 let's get into
the show Abby asked as a 24 year old how
can I turn a possible disadvantage like
being young into an advantage as a
speaker and a coach Abby the this is a
great question and first of all we
waited a long time to answer this right
she's been posting this on the gram for
a while India talking to you a long time
so first of all really appreciate the
hustle and the perseverance actually
listen tore up the show and tell you how
you can ask a question on the askgaryvee
show
[Music]
a bee
I mean you know it's funny I love your
hustle perseverance so much but I'm
gonna zing and Zang a little bit on this
answer because I am really tired of 21
19 22 24 year-olds wanting to be speaker
and coaches about things that they are
not able to speak in coach about because
they don't have the experience you're
right it is a disadvantage it's very
hard for me to want to listen or pay you
for business advice when you've never
built a business and by the way you
don't to be 24 you can be 39 and trying
to sell business advice when you've
never sold a business now that's making
me me making a leap and an assumption
that that's what you want to talk about
if you want to talk about the
perspective of a millennial on how to
use social media because you are one
cool if you want to talk about the
things you've learned you know in
whatever genre if you've been making
music since you were 13 and you're 24
that's an 11-year career but the truth
is you can only talk about and demand
and command attention and respect around
something you've actually accomplished
just saying that you're a coach when a
speaker doesn't mean you are one because
you just said you are one you've got to
earn the credit to be able to do it now
look I do I believe that you can be a
football coach without playing football
yes but we've hit on this before when
you look at the coaches that were
coaches that you know didn't play
football
most of them played college football
maybe they can't get to the pros most of
them if they didn't play football at
least at bare minimum played high school
football competitively and then had a
father normally who was a coach or was
within the organization of a major
sports franchise I mean yeah you've got
to put in the work and so you know the
reason there's that
disadvantage of being 24 and getting
people to listen to you is cuz they're
right now there's anomalies maybe you
were 17 and you built a huge business
and sold it at 21 the age is not the
variable you know I feel like I did a
lot by 24 I could walk onto stage and
say hey guys in the last 24 months
since I was 22 and I took over my dad's
business I've taken it in the last 24
months from 3 to 15 million dollars
here's how I did it that's some
credibility that's some chops but I
couldn't have at that point say let me
talk to you about HR as a leader mmm
only 24 months of that experience only
so much value compared to when I do it
now of having two decades of doing it so
you know it's a disadvantage for a
purpose right for a reason if you're an
anomaly radical but if you're not you
need to respect that people are not
idiots
Hans asks what do you think about the
recent Twitter acquisition of periscope
Hans is a tremendous question as we are
filming this right now so everybody
who's listening I'm gonna have the rock
show Stefan right now who's actually
filming us and mere counting come on
flip over the flip over to screen show
the camera flip over your screen zoom
indie-rock then a flipbook not don't
look at you show dick there we go thank
you yeah so you know right now we are we
were mere catting I don't know if you
know that but that's an actual animal
you can go back to me I think if I was
meerkat I'd be very concerned you know
obviously we're all enjoying the cat
quite a bit live-streaming phone to
phone peer-to-peer is clearly here but
uh but if I was meerkat I would be
concerned about this acquisition because
clearly if it's got the same
functionality which is what it's rumored
to have I haven't seen it yet but I will
probably test it out this weekend if I
get a chance at South by Southwest Oh
which reminds me if you're going to
South by Southwest please check out my
talk Saturday at 3 p.m.
Austin time I I think that I become
and I think that I'm definitely gonna
check it out because I should and
because it's gonna be integrated
probably natively into the Twitter app
so it will be interesting to see this
play out if it's gonna be a fast move by
by Twitter to integrate we've seen this
before you know I remember people saying
Oh
Facebook's doing check-ins for squares
dead and it didn't happen because it
wasn't needed to the product but I do
think this functionality clearly cuz
meerkats built on top of Twitter from
the sign-in from the push out from the
engagement when people are commenting
right now it's showing up on Twitter
this is deeply integrated into Twitter
and thus will be interesting to watch
what what what happens here I absolutely
plan on using it I see a scenario where
this is really detrimental to meerkat I
see a scenario where Twitter tries to
see if both can survive I don't know
it'll be interesting to watch but the
the acquisition has definitely caught my
attention I'm paying very close
attention and I on testing out the
product as soon as possible so I can
make my judgments on differences
samantha asks how do you write hooks
different for a free service versus a
paid one when you're throwing a right
hook that's free I get excited because
there's less friction and it feels like
I'm gonna really be able to land that
right hook the problem is there's a
really funny thing about free free
creates a scenario where people value it
for what it's been put out it's really
interesting I think that a lot of people
who watch this show value it quite a bit
I think that the 10% left if I started
charging four bucks an episode or two
bucks an episode the you know actually
you know what that's gonna be the
question of the day and I know this is a
tough question and by the way I will not
be charging for this so don't worry
don't hedge and say zero I don't have
any plans on it but if I was what would
you pay to watch an episode of the
askgaryvee show and and yeah that's the
real question and and clearly I expect
most of the comments to be zero or no
because I rec specs that there's so much
content out there but I do believe that
my content is better than a substantial
amount of content out there in the world
especially when it talks about new
platforms business running business
as leadership entrepreneurship startup
tech culture so I do think that we'll
see a surprising number and I'm sure
you're probably getting answers right
now and meerkat it's just a fun feel
free to not shout it out because I want
to be surprised but I do think that it's
really funny to me to think about the
10% of you that I would expect to pay
for it that if you were paying four
bucks for it you'd actually value the
show more it's really quite interesting
psychology so how do I act differently
one when I throw right hooks for example
when I tweet out later today that
episode 80 is up
duh you know I expect to land more than
saying episode 80 is up you know here
pay me in $3 snapcash if you want to
watch it you know I I I have a little
less angst of the conversion because I
know that there's no friction
financially which is one of the besides
time finances is the is the friction and
so I think it's got a totally different
cadence different expectation different
pressure hold I think it's easier hey
Gary
answer my question by the way go Giants
Ryan asks I work for a company that
makes animated explainer videos for
businesses is Google pay-per-click the
best option for b2b companies like us
Ryan great question really excited about
baseball right now I'd love to get your
comment in the sections about Brandon
Belt very much of my radar to draft this
year on fantasy baseball
hopefully nobody in the Vayner 20-man
fantasy baseball league is listening or
watching but I know Bobby Klein and
watch us on whatever percent now that he
has optics into what I'm doing though I
could be throwing him a curveball
listen Google pay-per-click is
tremendous but I also think that
LinkedIn ads have tremendous upside for
you also LinkedIn creative meaning
putting out blog posts on LinkedIn and
then having a call to action at the
bottom I think could actually work for
you quite a bit because the b2b
mentality within LinkedIn is so over the
top it's the context of the room so I'm
a big fan of putting out content now
that everybody can blog on LinkedIn and
then maybe use that content on your
email newsletter on your website on
other places where you have a little bit
of base to create some awareness around
it I'm a big fan of that
I actually think you could get
stunningly
stunning Hail Mary upside on both
Pinterest and and Instagram
I think Pinterest ad product that will
probably see rollout this year has a
chance to really matter for you if
you're actually targeting people in a
business world that could actually buy
this but yeah I would say Google I would
say I would say content I would say go
and reach out to any bdb platforms
podcasts and blogs that speak to the
audience that you're trying to reach and
see if your CEO or creative director can
be a guest contributor or interviewed on
there because that exposure I think
actually can convert for you maybe not
at the scale that you can get from a PPC
google world I also think you can target
people by their office you know by where
they work on Facebook dark posts and I
think you can get some really great
results there especially if you upload
some of the native videos that you
actually create in native Facebook form
I think you can actually get some
interesting results there so so do I
think Google PPC still wins the day for
you I think it's clearly gonna be one of
the three winners I think Facebook dark
posts and I think LinkedIn ads supported
by length and creative play and can
compete at that level so that's where I
would focus c.j asks what's your
favorite airport see this is a great
question my favorite airports are always
like like small ones like in Des Moines
or like you know which I've been to or
you know where does that you know South
something south we're in Greenville
South Carolina
you know Montana some one place I've
done Park and saw some of the stuff I've
done Chattanooga Tennessee
you know the airports you walk in oh
when we agree Mountain Coffee is a
client the Vermont Airport I mean you
know the airports that you could
literally roll up to and be at your gate
within let her know four minutes with no
pre-check you know I like those places I
also clearly feel very I mean yep Newark
JFK and LaGuardia have in some weird way
SFO I know everything about LAX SFO LGA
JFK and Newark I know those are inner
ports probably know the nuances of those
reports better and I know the office of
vaynermedia they've become my home big
shout out to Johnny at LGA I mean these
people have become my friends it's
really quite sad like like I almost feel
like they're breaking tsa rules like
they don't even need to check my ID
they're like hey Gary I'm like hey you
know like it's a you know so I got
really sad answer to this question
they're actually real authentic sad
answer this question is all of them the
coziness that I feel at an airport is
disturbing at best so cool let's do one
more added question I know there's a
delay but we'll sit here and jam let's
film Stefon actually let this all roldy
Rock know anything we're gonna ask a
meerkat question Steph honest new you
see one that you like because I know
there's a delay so they'll pop up in a
second pop popping away and you can just
ask one mm-hmm so there's no awkward
silence you can look at me and I can
just talk about something random
Darrelle Revis so goddamn happy so South
by Southwest my 7th or 8th year heading
down in a couple of hours hopefully you
know please hit me up on Twitter if
you're down there I'm trying to do some
random meetups and definitely come and
check out my talk I will stick around
after and like selfie it up
got anything what does it take to work
at vaynermedia that's a good question
thanks meerkat um he doesn't know that's
why I sent somebody but he got it it
scrolls yeah yeah it's over sorry if you
asked this question
uh no IP love um you know I think it
takes a million different things
depending on what the job is it's about
the right job for the right person so
the answer is if anybody probably could
work at Vayner at some level they just
have to have self-awareness if they are
a project manager or a creative director
account soup a cm but it definitely
takes I think the more interesting
question is what does it take to win at
vaynermedia right so getting in like
we've had plenty of winners and losers
get in but how
how to win here I think is a fine
balance of one having empathy and
self-awareness and respecting the others
around you having patience I think a lot
of people lose within the first six 12
18 months at Vayner because they're just
not playing the long game and they
either want a raise or a promotion or
have the audacity of like thinking
they're better than they are
but while equally is back to pulling in
both directions
I want that bravado and confidence and
all those things so I think it's about
making networks having relationships
having self-awareness having patience /
communication you know like what if what
if this machine is doing bad by you I
respect that
we're not perfect I want to be there for
you so are you speaking to many in HR or
me or AJ or your or your leaders within
the organization or these 30 to 50
people here that have been here for a
year or two three years that are really
the foundation of the ethos of the
company so you know I I think there's a
lot of different things that it takes
but it definitely takes hard work it
definitely takes smarts it take but what
Trump's that is it takes heart you
didn't yet
Lauzon Burke oh cool great job hey les
oh great you searched yeah great job
India I'm proud of you you keep asking
questions
India will keep finding them by the way
do you see my pants
these are nice new pants you like him I
like they're not really Burgundy yeah
look a Burt well they're not orange the
fun nobody have like yeah they're maroon
but like but like like they're like
Klenner anyway I mean and the fact that
the meerkat caught it loose please tweet
out the d-roc it up
actually I'm pissed it wasn't part of
the show because that would've got him
mad but I would have loved the real [ __ ]
all right
some a month some per episode give me
that
what Sam
reverse hey guys confidence is key
cockiness is the lock that can open any
door or the difference everybody how are
you hmm
lad said hey to India that's nice hey
Lars any not chatting anymore uh where's
the question oh I didn't do a question
yeah I did a question day in the episode
yeah um hey hey hey d-roc is awesome
this is crap hey Rach what do you think
Tim said that hey India from India um
I'm hustling in Russia Carrie love you
too hey India from India I gotta figure
that out Jason Pleau Rico love it
there was a question of day guys it was
intermingled you didn't watch this is
nuts thanks for show you got it great
show thank you the beard is coming in
right you guys didn't know I could grow
up here like this huh all right the
playoff beard yeah it comes in good a
very nice the beer I am prepping for
Ryan Fitzpatrick my new quarterback like
you Sonic reference a few shows thang
chops off teen pizza or teen burrito
neither muscle Mike wouldn't let me
eating like eating either do you think
meerkat could do a dating version if the
chops off um yeah the answer is yes I'm
sure there's plenty of interesting
what's that I have my wife I love that
we caught it live epic episode thank you
Richard you feel meerkat is starting to
explode Jaden I think it's clearly
gaining traction it's still nerd it out
when you get the first couple big
celebrities to do it and we have like
you know I'm pumped at a 517 if you want
to jump in here but like when there's
14th that when when you get one of these
grape story celebrities that has like
44,000 on because it's all teenage girl
culture you know they'll be interesting
why don't you watch your own videos ego
or time John you know time I don't know
ego I don't know if I'm like trying to
be cooler than myself
is this a battle
me myself I don't watch my own videos
cuz I know what I [ __ ] did like I
watched it already
Rosie thanks the beard love thank you a
lot of people asked me not to get rid of
the beard it's really what do you think
I did you know like the beard what do
you like to be under like is that like a
weird question that I put your new merit
spot there I'm sorry about that the new
Ustream Q&A yeah Luke this definitely
has the potential to do so Luke it's
been with me for a long time we still do
use screen q and A's like it was our job
back in like oh seven oh eight oh nine
so super fun what's your favorite red
wine right now Rosie there's a mail back
that Wine Library is going to offer in
two weeks if you're not if you go to
winelibrary.com right now we have a new
pop-up that can sign you up for the
email us you should sign up because in
to Wednesdays
one of my favorite wines of all time for
thirty forty dollars is this Argentinian
Malbec of blew me away and we're gonna
do for $19.99 by the case or maybe even
by the bottle brain is debating that but
blows me away so she'll be our tea I've
been seeing him hit me up what are
social beards what is joining us on
social beards Sbarro's I've seen you hit
me up on it's like I mean does that mean
he wants me to follow them I don't know
how long I'm gonna I feel like I'm not
gonna keep the beard I'm gonna do like a
weird I think I'm gonna do like I'm
gonna do yeah I'm gonna do a whole
handlebars thing I think I'm gonna do it
I think oh wow I did it once on a
Spanish wine trip for 17 days when I
came home Lizzie like lost or living
like we were just together for like two
years she open the door she's like I
didn't seen her for 17 there longest
time we were apart and you know early
love you know opens don't you think yeah
I might just keep the under like I might
just everything you know just keep this
yeah
cipolla you can do what can you do for
me
pull up your something you can do for me
I want all 535 people who are watching
this right now to go on skitzer or or
iTunes and follow the podcast
leave a review to the podcast I need
that um because I'm trying to you know
for me when you're putting on content
people discovering your content is so
important so you guys as a community
getting you know Twitter's got so noisy
that you know people giving me love on
Twitter is nice but blog post or podcast
reviews or Instagram is huge like taking
a screenshot of this right now oh you
know be awesome actually you're the fun
social here's a right hook in the
[ __ ] half taking a screenshot of this
right now so I'm actually gonna wait a
second be like taking a screenshot of
this right now and then putting out an
instant photo and giving me some love
that would be that is like a hardcore
right hook ask but but would be a big
deal for me because really I'm obsessed
with when you're putting out content
you're looking for distribution I
believe that humans and your fans are
the biggest distribution
I believe that my fans over-index with
giving me love on Twitter I believe the
attention graph on Twitter is getting
hurt so I need to siphon that into the
places that matter to me right now which
is sketcher and you know and and iTunes
for the podcast because I want to build
up the podcast a little bit it's
definitely Instagram so that would
really really really mean a lot to me
screenshot of this and then my handle at
Gary Vee on Instagram and you know just
like a right hook to the community if
you have listened I I feel like that's a
big right hook you don't have to do it
but that would be a huge deal I would be
really really happy
d-roc [ __ ] up chris chris is a
olympian yeah yeah he's [ __ ] awesome
so done it'd be really bad ass if you
reviewed my podcast we're in the hunt
where to hunt Wisconsin podcast that's
awesome we're too high oh no I don't
want to [ __ ] you I barely I'm barely
catching up with my email so the chances
of me actually listening to the podcast
and then being able to review because I
would never review it without watching I
feel that's not authentic in the same
way that I would never want anybody here
to take a screenshot and post on their
install or leave a review if they don't
feel comfortable so pro tip for South by
Daniel don't get caught up in too many
scheduling things the serendipity has
all the action serendipity has all the
action Rosie thinks for a screen shot
who's your favorite youtuber and why
again I don't
soon I put out content I don't consume
it I can signor Conte in the time that
most of you it's not a dish most of
everybody would spend maybe these ten
minutes maybe watching something they
like or listening to something or
reading like things that I think I could
have seen myself doing if I didn't go
rogue like reading grant land for ten
minutes right now or you know like what
I'm doing is I'd rather give back to my
community right now and jam with you
guys right so my consumption is has been
converted into my interaction yeah
that's what it is my consumption is my
interaction you know you got it yeah my
consumption like why I don't consume
media it's because all those extra
minutes are going into answering P and
you know what's in the end I want to go
hardcore let's take a bunch of the like
I don't think people recognize how much
email I get love like life story and
then I have to read it and then respond
and we'll X out people's names and such
and if then we'll use the generic ones
like hey like how do I crush it you know
but like you know like like yeah that's
you know that's what it is
my um that's my consumption so I don't
consume anything do you still lift hell
yeah I can start to happen for me but
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait another
year when it's I finally like have
something here it's crazy Instagram is
easy ask consider it done thank you so
much
the life of Nadia I love that thank you
so much actually not what Jason for
China that's awesome I need to check
that out when you're gonna hit up Bayway
liquor next baby that's so funny I've
known the people that own that store my
whole life like do you think I own
Bayway liquors cuz I don't but Wine
Library is 15 minutes from a way and I
love those guys I hope they're doing
well Instagram pic added and tagged you
don't do I'm missing class for this
that's the best investment you've ever
made here's my right hook holy crap he
lost a ton of weight good for him
he looks great yeah see this is what
pissed me off I lost 20 pounds that
nobody even knows thank you for
delivering alright I gotta get out of
here
romi you waiting for me alright I gotta
get roaming she's been waiting forever
see
you